There was a dog named Patrasche.
His master was a cruel and evil man.
"Pull the cart! I don't care whether you are tired or not! You are a useless dog!"
He kicked Patrasche and threw him to the roadside.
After a few days, an old man and a boy walked by.
"Look at that poor dog! He looks dead."
The boy ran to the dog.
"He's still alive! Let's take him home."
The old man, Jehan, felt pity for the dog.
He couldn't say 'no' to his grandson.
Jehan and Nello were very poor but lived happily near the city of Antwerp.
Jehan took milk from the villagers and sold it in town.
Patrasche was soon well again.
One morning, Patrasche stood in front of the cart.
"No, Patrasche, you don't have to do that."
"Okay. If you really want to pull the cart, you can."
One day, Jehan was too sick to go to Antwerp.
"It's okay, grandfather. Patrasche and I can take the milk to town."
"Are you sure?"
"Yes, grandfather. Don't worry. You just rest at home."
After that, Nello and Patrasche took milk to town.
Nello went into a big church whenever they went to Antwerp.
Patrasche wondered what Nello did in the church.
He tried to come in to the church.
"No, dirty dog! Dogs can't enter the church."
Patrasche walked into the church when the guard wasn't looking.
Patrasche saw Nello staring at a painting.
There were three paintings by Rubens but two were covered by curtains.
"Patrasche, we have to pay money to see those two. Someday I'll see them."